the jurgen experience there's gonna be
conspiracy theories about why mike tyson
lit that dude up on that plane that's
what i mean real simple that dude was a
douchebag and he was like you see the
other videos annoying one of the baddest
[ __ ] that's ever walked the
face of the earth talk about kicking a
beehive what the [ __ ] are you doing dude
that's not even kicking a beehive it's
like smashing it's head butting a
beehive it's like trying to put your
dick in a sleeping bear's mouth
like he just walked up and was like i'm
gonna lower my wiener right into the
bear's mouth mike tyson also there's a
video that came out of the angle of him
talking to someone and he's like talking
[ __ ] in a way where you're like this
guy's hammered and doesn't know what's
coming
because i bet in his head he's like he
won't punch me he can't punch me
oh my god i bet he's a guy that thinks
mike tyson's hands are registered lethal
weapon
he strikes me as that guy he's like
and he by the way i saw the guys shape
and i was like that guy kicked the [ __ ]
out of me well it's so much better than
the things that make you confident yeah
things that make you confident are
dangerous like that's what it means like
or booze and you get mike tyson punching
on you on a jet blue flight yeah yeah
that guy's probably on a bunch of [ __ ]
the guy who uh mike tyson punched
apparently according to the new york
post uh has a lengthy criminal history
uh
well
in that case if he's if he's had a lot
of [ __ ] ups and he's a you know a bad
person whatever he's gonna go to jail at
least he got to get his ass kicked by a
famous person if you find yourself or
mike tyson's reaching over the back of
an airline seat and punching you in the
face i think you probably earned it
i think you probably earned it yeah i i
don't think he [ __ ] you climb into uh
i don't think it was for kicking his
chair right i don't think he was he's a
[ __ ] guy was super annoying man yeah
and he was like over the thing you just
kidding yeah it's like people get crazy
they think that just because he's
uh you know he's mike tyson he's famous
he can't just punch you you're annoying
him he's gonna just [ __ ] hit you like
a normal person would you know hecklers
do that though yeah some you know that
like they'll be talking and you're like
hey shut the [ __ ] up
right
but
you're like you can't talk yeah they
didn't bring you down here they didn't
put you up at the [ __ ] extended stay
they're not amplifying you and stop stop
talking that's why booze when people are
like when i have friends like i'm coming
to your show dude we're going to the bar
first
who wants to get drunk and sit silently
in a dark room no one who you want to
get drunk and go pay attention not only
that like if there's a guy who thinks he
might be funny that's the time they all
think they're funny yeah they want to do
i don't know what to do
i got you oh and then you know the
classic after the show i helped and
you're like man i helped yeah i wonder
if that guy was like i helped that fight